Muhammad al-hassari is a builder he says
he paid Libyan Smugglers four thousand
dollars to take him to Italy where he
hoped to find work to feed his family he
was one of an estimated 750 people on a
fishing trawler he says was fit to carry
half that number he described how the
Smugglers loaded people onto the boat at
a remote Mooring
two fishing boats ferried people to the
boat in batches of 20. I was among the
last 10 and the bot was swaying side to
side I asked a friend is this boat safe
he didn't answer everyone was afraid
everyone understood this was going to be
a difficult Journey
when the boat was spotted 47 miles off
Greece in the ionian sea this is what it
looked like al-husry believes it sank
because its engine failed while the ship
was moving it had some balance but when
it stopped it started to Lurch some
survivors believe that the Greek Coast
Guard vessel that was trying to help
them inadvertently harmed them
we spoke to one of these Witnesses
Mahmoud shalabi is not his real name
the cost got tied her up to the port
side of the bouts the bottle-ledged side
to side as they told it and when they
cut the rope it ledged suddenly
shalabi said the Coast Guard tried to
cover up the incident after the trawler
capsized
they started pulling us out of the water
and they would hit us with a floating
ring and tell Arsenal to talk they said
you will not talk about these events
both Witnesses said there were perhaps a
hundred women and children below decks
none survived
these two witnesses along with dozens of
other survivors have been deposed by the
Greek Coast Guard when they arrived
onshore and their testimonies are going
to be included in a Judicial inquiry now
underway at the Supreme Court level to
find out exactly what happened Greece
has arrested nine Egyptian survivors as
suspected human traffickers but shalabi
told me the real operators were
well-armed Libyan militiamen who stacked
him and 150 other Egyptians into a truck
and drove them through little-known
mountain passes to the departure point a
concealed Cove West of tobrook and on
the way he saw something of the scale of
their operation
there are five Bots being prepared a
kilometer Inland and preparing them for
the forthcoming voyages Europe has
decried the inhumanity of the Smugglers
but it hasn't found an effective way to
defeat their thriving business
John saropoulos Al Jazeera malacasa